in several of my movie interpretation
videos
i've documented the rise of
propagandistic patterns in recent
storytelling
the new intersectional ideal coupled
with the revolutionary patterns so
common in hollywood tropes
have merged together to create
quote-unquote
woke stories which use storytelling
tools to impose an
upside-down pattern of reality this
happens through a desire to counteract
the negative side effects of identity
such as exclusion and oppression of
margins and so although
the aims are understandable there are
inevitable side effects
of going down that line in order to
fight stereotypes and traditional
hierarchies
one creates characters and narratives
which try to upend and counteract them
but what first looks like just
counteracting them becomes
mainstream and even expected creating
stories with
upside down stereotypes so a woman
must systematically beat up men the
exceptional
must be better than the rule the
outsider better than the one inside
the margin must replace the center while
remaining the margin
i need you to fix his suit the suit is
literal perfection
it will be when it fits a woman
things become upside down when by social
pressures and strange new taboos these
new
counter-intuitive stereotypes become an
enforced expected
norm
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
many people have complained as they
watch their
favorite franchises being taken over by
such practices
there are too many franchises to
enumerate from star wars men in black
james bond to different comic book
characters
video game series the latest being the
new enola homes movie on netflix
paint your own picture and ola don't be
thrown of course by other people
especially men one of the complaints
made by
critics of these strategies is found in
asking
why the new intersectional thinkers
don't
just make up new characters and
storylines rather than
infiltrate and take over existing ones
by asking this one ignores how
contemporary
woke activism is born out of a
deliberately
parasitic approach to being the activist
type
understands that the current narratives
are in some respect
the vehicles of power and normativity
this plays out in the analogy between
the human
body and the body politic and so like a
virus can destabilize the human body
so too the ideological parasite will
destabilize the body politic
so although one can always you know
openly oppose
the most powerful tool is by infecting
structures and subverting power
thereby acting in complete coherence
with the revolutionary world view
this parasitic relationship is not an
accident but is the very
pattern of how they think reality works
and what they see
as their place in the larger system
normativity can only be subverted
it can only be deconstructed i've
discussed why postmodern thinkers think
see themselves as social viruses and
infections so i don't want to go into it
too much here
what i mostly want to look at is how
there is also a secret solution
within this pattern of storytelling
we've noticed how the pattern of
replacement has appeared in so many
instances
where the main characters represented as
the normative ones are killed
or humiliated inverted or replaced
the strangest versions of this are those
characters who happily see their place
to others fitting in the intersectional
world view
so the strategy of those enacting these
new story tropes
is not so much for woke culture to give
us new stories and characters
but to deconstruct and ultimately take
over existing cultural forms and stories
from the inside if in religion we might
not see a new religious figure
but rather see christ represented as
genderqueer
in storytelling we will not necessarily
see a new superhero but rather
have lady thor replace a lazy fat
self-wallowing thor
just like any parasite this pattern of
course cannot hold at least not for long
just like any revolutionary approach to
reality what do you do when you win
what happens when all the superheroes
and video game characters and science
fiction franchises
and even saints have been replaced by
their woke selves
when a parasite kills its host it can
only move on to another house but when
it has devoured all the hosts
in its sight then it will itself die
so parasitic patterns of storyteller
storytelling must by their very nature
reaffirm what they're attacking they
need their host to survive
for their story to make sense they know
they can't win without
being seen as the losers just like the
progressive thinker accuses the
conservative
or nationalist of othering that is
needing to identify
outside outsiders and marginal
identities in order to consolidate one's
own identity through
opposition to a dangerous outside the
revolutionary thinker
must perpetually self other this might
seem like a paradox
but saying the revolutionary must
practice a form of self
othering means that the revolutionary
must repeat
reenact recast almost ritually stories
and tropes
which he or she or the category they are
allied with
is marginalized and oppressed by a
system of order and identity
so they must be victims of an oppressive
system
it is in their very identity that this
is so
and there is even a reverse
proportionality where the revolutionary
voice becomes
stronger as it is winning it accelerates
perpetuates
ad nauseum and almost hysterically
stories of oppression
and marginalization this was of course
true of
communist regimes where once the
revolution has succeeded it never led to
the dissolution
of the state touted by marx but rather
led to the need of
positing a constant and powerful
counter-revolution always
invisibly present and ready to impose
the old hierarchies
so even as the revolutionary narrative
is winning
it will nonetheless always represent
itself as the victim
evergreen catches diversity checks but
doesn't give a [ __ ] about blacks
and so the paradox of holding the
revolutionary position
is that one must constantly re-posit and
re-enact the old order
in recent storytelling the most
successful of the new franchises
have been those who manifest this
pattern of replacement within their own
story
so it's not just about showing an ideal
world of diversity inclusivity
and celebration of the margin one must
first establish a somewhat normal body
to then undermine it so the first part
of a series the first movie
will seem to establish a somewhat
traditional pattern of storytelling
but then when fans are attached to the
characters the parasite is lit loose
and the story is undermined the pattern
is flipped upside down the main
characters are humiliated
and so we experience the reversal in
real time
this reversal is framed to act as a
strange catharsis
needed by woke adherents to participate
in and also
partly alleviate the original sin of
woke religion
this was the case with the recent
controversy around the last of us
part 2 video game in which the main
character
from the first game is beaten to death
in early stages of the game
but it was also what happened to the
fans of westworld
and it is the entire narrative arc of
stranger things
where an 80s boys club coming of age
story is structured in a way to be
overwhelmed and taken over by a powerful
female character
this could have been fine as a basic
story but this same pattern
is repeated in micro levels of each
narrative
ramping up towards the third season of
stranger things when
feminine characters had taken up most
significant action and relationships of
power
one of the most important scenes in all
of stranger things
one which acts as a microcosm of the
whole series
is where we find the resolution of the
arc of bad boy steve
carrington presented as an insensitive
but attractive and popular bully in the
first season
the character is humiliated as the bad
guy
should but he then goes through this own
arc and to become a more mature
character this buildup seems to be
moving towards
him giving attention and entering in a
relationship with his coworker robin
but this connection is upended by
intersectional
considerations tammy thompson's a girl
steve another recent example i happen to
stumble upon is nexflix's umbrella
academy
where the first season presents a story
of a ragtag team of characters
with positive and negative aspects and
spoiler alert leads to the trope of
someone destroying the world because of
resentment
yet the second season reduces all the
male characters to bumbling
idiots and indulges only the image of
the pathetic father
taking up the praise song of your press
classes rising up to defeat the system
of course the second season got much
better reviews than the first
and so it is dangerous to be comforted
when we
see some glimmer of traditional story
tropes appear
for what we should expect in the coming
years are stories which
establish a certain order in their
opening stages
only to then undermine that order once
the story is on its way
this will be repeated in an almost
liturgical fashion as woke culture
spread through society as we watch this
accelerate
the attentive person will have what some
call a red pill moment and notice that
the seeds of this were already
planted long ago in many of the stories
they once loved
and so even as people cry for the
subversive and revolutionary trope of
woke ideas taking over star wars they
will realize that the seed of this
was in many respects an aspect of the
story
all along i bypassed the compressor
of course the secret here and the reason
why i am going through the trouble
of explaining this is that there is also
a silver lining
in this for those storytellers who are
attentive
they need to recast the center as the
enemy to defeat
to do it over and over means that the
space of the center is always
open because identity is inevitable and
because the stories that last
are always those which manifest the
pattern of the world
there are ways to recast the central
figure once
the deconstruction is finished the
margin needs the center to have
something to rebel against
and in that the smart ones on the margin
will play a role
in bringing it back there are a few
examples of this in history the most
infamous
might be the decadent satanic author j.k
hussmans in the end of the 19th century
who wrote thinly veal veiled
biographical
novels about romping through degenerate
satanist circles
of early modern france only to pivot
towards a conversion to catholicism
and novels on the symbolism of christian
cathedrals ending his life
as a benedictine oblate there are also
more modern versions
in the mediocre film the libertine with
johnny depp
a despicable iconoclast and libertine
rides his excesses to a point where his
entire life is falling apart
but ends his days converting to
christianity and defending the king
so for those watching the narratives the
story trope to look for
and to engage with is the story of the
return of the king
which of course happens at the end of
lord of the rings but more traditionally
is also the resolution
of the robin hood story where an
illegitimate and resentful king
establishes a corrupt rule only to be
chased out when the lion heart returns
more recently this is also the
resolution of the black panther movie
where t'challa's cousin killmonger is
presented as a resentful revolutionary
who wants to use power to destroy the
current social
structures although one can have
sympathy for his cause
and the suffering he endured he must
nonetheless die
and make way for the legitimate ruler in
the end
so as we see the continual ramping up of
propagandistic storytelling
one must continue to pay attention to
places
where balance and in stories appears
and to those who can remember that this
is our time
tell better stories it's up to us i know
i will be trying
so i hope this was useful and thank you
for your attention
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism
get involved i love to read your
insights and questions in the comments
section
you can also share this video on social
media to your friends
and if you can please consider
supporting us financially
through patreon or paypal you'll find
those links in the description below